what's up guys quick moment just want to
say thank you to one of our sponsors for
one of our long time sponsors this is on
it let's get right into it
www.onmit.com forward slash Yola or
click the link and wherever you're
listening to this link is below in the
description or if you're on YouTube it's
right in the comments or in the video
description prior to the show ever even
being thought of Marty has been using on
it for what a decade that is correct
that is correct creep
good
I'm almost done yeah that is correct and
you guys already know Alpha Brain is one
of the Staples of their company but is
now in shot form so brand new Alpha
Brain instant Focus shot and black label
these come in little shots just like you
would see at the store there's Peach
there's tropical there's a bunch of
different flavors but this is Alpha
Brain this is to make you hyper focused
I just watched the Rogan show the other
day he says he is never not done a show
without Alpha Brain remember
www.onic.com
o-n-n-i-t.com forward slash Yola so as
we always say thank you guys for
supporting every time you click that
link for on it every time you buy
something with our code it really helps
us out guys this is this is how we get
stuff done the sponsors help us make
this show better thank you guys for
supporting the brands that support us
foreign
[Music]
hey what's up everybody welcome back to
the dope as usual podcast I am Thomas
dobachola whatever you want to call me
I'm here with Marty O'Neal what's up how
you guys doing this is dope's usual
podcast we're here to talk about life
drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between today we have a
very special guest
Dr TV host radio personality and much
more Dr Drew very kind of the view to
say but here I am I'm I was you you're
not just a doctor that's why I'm looking
at I was trying to think how am I going
to intro him well he's not just a doctor
I think about myself as that first
though
that's all that's number one number one
I mean it was such a it was such it was
such a long road to get where I got and
then I was deep in it the the workahol
is around medicine for two decades
really and I sort of had like almost
four careers in one that's what I've
been seeing yeah it's weird and and it's
because I was workaholic and uh I just
was interested I just loved everything I
was doing it was just so interesting so
I ended up in on one hand going deep
into working in a psychiatric hospital
and running departments there and at the
same time doing general medicine in a
hospital and also as an outpatient
okay I saw something while you were
still in medical school you started some
doing something on the radio called ask
a surgeon no so yes and no so uh in 1983
I was living I don't know if you know
Pasadena but K-Rock was in Pasadena oh
the radio station K-Rock was right
across the street from and
any any of your but at your age or
younger cannot appreciate the power of
radio at the time oh I can radio was
like it's everything it was everything
you organized your culture around it
your day around it it defined who you
were and at that time it's 1982 83
everyone was listening to KLOS kmet and
the music got super boring and uh out of
nowhere K-Rock came out of nowhere and I
was living a block away from KRON and
friends of mine started meeting and
socializing with people at K-Rock and
some one guy called me goes hey they're
doing this show in the middle of the
night it's called Loveline and they want
you to come on and do a segment called
ask a surgeon they want you to use use
big words it'll be really funny and I
was like why are you what the [ __ ]
why are you calling me why are you
calling me why are you bothering me with
this and I thought well it's interesting
I'm starting to listen to that station
it's kind of cool might be an
interesting opportunity and so I agreed
to meet with the guys that were doing it
and went up there and was blown away by
the fact that this is where young people
were bringing their most important
health questions in the middle of the
night it was Sunday night at midnight to
3 A.M it was it had been designed
because the program director needed a
community service show and so the reason
they were struggling with what to do
with this they needed to turn it into an
informational community service show and
they'll have pinsky's in medical school
maybe he can talk about something you
know right and wow yeah I know
ridiculous but cool but but at the same
time uh one Anthony fauci was somebody I
admired greatly I was deep in the AIDS
pandemic I was I just I was telling
people they were going to die all day
long that's all I did and he was telling
us we got to go out and educate he kept
saying there could be two million death
I think two million dead you got to go
educate and I was so stunned when I went
into the radio station that night that
none of the young people that were
calling in they were calling about all
kinds of stuff but they'd not heard
about this what we were just starting to
call AIDS because she said 1983 yeah
they didn't hadn't heard of it and it
was but it was already panned endemic at
that point so crazy
so I'm sorry that I'm being texted like
crazy so it's one of my problems as
things reign in on me no worries I
figure the doctor like yeah he's never
non-stop still an active doctor yes yes
yeah yeah no no take your time all right
keep going so go ahead so you
a fluke came in just to yeah and I just
thought hey can I keep coming back and I
think this is kind of interesting
important I I'd come it was one night a
week in the middle of the night and so
if I was on call or something I didn't
go and practicing medical doctor no I
was in I was finishing medical school
and we became a resident and um but I
you know the schedule then was insane
and um you know I'd go in for an hour or
two and then I'd leave and it's kind of
interesting I'd be interesting people
you know it's just fun it was different
and I thought I was doing community
service you are and I did it for 10
years one night a week every week not
every week I mean well there's many
variations on the theme over that
10-year period and it was I it was
community service that's what I thought
I was doing I was not paid it was
interesting it was fun
um and uh
it uh for a while I stopped because my
residency director made me he told me I
was something wrong with me and I was it
was right before fauci really went
public with
doctors have to educate about AIDS and
talk about sexual behaviors and it was
like three months before that he just
went off on me and told me there's
something wrong with you you're going to
ruin your career with you know and I was
like giving information and uh and then
when fauci came out and said you've got
all doctors have to get out the in the
media and start talking about this uh
two years later that guy walked into me
in the hall and said hey you still doing
that radio show I'd stopped for six
months and then I kind of trickled back
because I thought it was important
um and he goes I'll tell you what I'll
take over now let me do it and I was
like are you like I I should I can't
even believe you're seeing that but you
know whatever so we ended up teaching
medicine I taught in through at the Keck
SC medical school I taught through
Department of Medicine then I depart I
taught through the department of
adolescent medicine and then I taught
through Psychiatry uh so I had three
different clinics jack of all trades as
a doctor as it sounds ridiculous it was
it was so crazy was that your first step
into any kind of entertainment anything
right community service I thought I was
doing educational radio yeah yeah yeah
and I didn't want anybody to think I was
promoting myself that's why I never used
my last name I just wanted to do the
just do the thing I see what you're
saying yeah that's a good way to take
that's a good take on that that was just
what that was I just went and it was you
know it was it was uh at the time
Cutting Edge you can't quite appreciate
how extreme that was to be talking to
young people about sexual behavior major
radio stations oh my God they're crazy
and uh so I also didn't want to be
called out for it particularly either I
just thought it was important so yeah
that's how it all started so you did
Loveline for how long 35 years
wow my age yeah wow you know I was
thinking about it when I was lying in
bed this morning went to bed early 9 30
last night I got up at 7 30 I thought
I used to come home every night at 12 30
and they get up at 6 30 and for years
and so so many lives that you've
directly impacted though legitimately
I I don't think of it that way I I think
of it as sort of treating the culture
the culture was it's been so and my
little idea at the very beginning was
radio had had such a negative impact on
you know the whole sex drugs and rock
and roll man I saw what was happening
with the drug addiction I saw what was
happening with AIDS I'm like maybe we
can use that same environment to move
things in a positive direction
what a direction to go to though that's
what that's an amazing direction to
start going towards and it's kind of
taboo when you're of course practicing
doctor too to do it was all way out
there stuff but but it just was a strong
Instinct I had there was something that
was the right thing it was a good thing
to do and history I think is judging it
prop well I know who knows I'm assuming
these days everything that was good is
bad so who knows it'll turn battles yes
yes there's a generation out there that
listened to you for every internet free
internet you didn't have any of that
information that's right and I was 24
years old and my sort of weird little
notion was I want to create something
that would have helped me when I was 17
18 19. exactly I had to I and by the way
that's why we did the show oh good and
the and the information that I had was
so easy it was not like you shouldn't
have access to it it was this bacteria
causes gonorrhea here's the antibiotic
you take for it here are the symptoms
and nobody ever discussed that stuff
crazy I think it would be public
knowledge at that point oh my God no
there was hidden behind Latin phrases
called them venereal diseases and even
something as simple as vaginal yeast was
called manilaises you know we had all
these it was ridiculous it was insane
and it was just you know it should have
been no different than talking about
sinus discharges or anything of course
of course and by the way that was a
novel idea that I felt that way it was
sort of it considered weird and yeah you
know off the chain but now that's actual
full-on shows
well you're the first person to really
like you said talk about taboo things to
an audience that had never experienced
anything but but the the
I I was very clear these things should
not be taboo I was very clear yes and
that's about that's what I mean is in
school and it wasn't being done and I
knew sorry I still I've had covet twice
and still got a little cough left over
oh it's good times
so but the trust me Omicron is a lot
less than the big one than Alpha was or
Delta
um
but I I uh what was oh yeah I knew what
shaped Behavior because I was shaping it
towards I was a young person yeah and I
knew it yeah and I was like I know this
sex education they're learning the
material they're not changing their
behavior that was the thing and they now
we're making that same mistake with
covet I can't believe we're doing the
same thing we did
40 years ago in terms of what you don't
change People's Health behaviors by
telling them what to do mandating them
what to do shaming them what they think
we could have shame people for being
sexually active we could think you think
that would have changed they would have
flipped us off and said we'll do
whatever we want exactly and now what
you need what you have to have is a case
so you you like leveling a call would
come in that was a case and that case
was a relatable Source somebody their
age their ethnicity whatever it might be
and their narrative they follow then I
make sense of the narrative we point out
the consequences of their choices we use
humor there's music that's it that's why
I got involved with Teen Mom I knew that
would have the same impact it's a
therapy session also uh no it absolutely
is not no no therapy is what the way I'm
saying it information it's information
but if you're telling somebody here's
your consequences it's well but remember
I want everybody else the the the the
the case they only listen so much but
everybody listening they learn a lot
they it gets through to them because we
do it over and over and over again
people people don't change by pointing
out much of anything intellectual to
them they they they
have to come to it themselves and I'm
sure I was a piece of helping them come
to their realizations whatever they
might be as they grow up but but I have
no illusions that therapy is never about
telling people what to do ever oh okay
ever just hearing them out it's getting
them to the point where they have
insight into what they've done and
internally want to motivate change and
and you just keep guiding them towards
takes forever it takes a long time but
that's how real change occurs that's to
come from inside you know you know you
need to take your penicillin and start
wearing a condom yeah it's not an
intervention style thing that doesn't
ever work it just doesn't work
intervention interventions are
interventions are very simple
interventions are come with us and get
some treatment or we can't be in your
life anymore that's what we did to my
dad it worked immediately yeah that's
what you're doing pointer fingers at him
no no you just tell him we love you but
we can't be a part of this because we're
watching you die that's exactly what we
did and he straightened up that's
intervention but this idea is like don't
you see the heroine is killing your
family yeah they know the heroine sucks
they have to do it that's the disease
that's illness so you mentioned
something about Teen Mom I did not know
I've never watched the show I just know
I thought you're writing our demo oh is
that no you're not in our demo at all so
I'm not surprised no well the reason I
bring it up is a Merced where I'm from
uh for two years in a row we were the
number one teen pregnancy uh population
in the country wow along with STDs under
25. fabulous congratulations that's what
I'm saying I've seen I'm one of my only
friends and my entire generation doesn't
have a child do you see what I'm saying
yeah when I was 21 my family's you don't
have a kid yet oh no I don't have a kid
I have a goals in my life and I couldn't
have raised a I couldn't have raised a
lizard at 21. no seriously no way yeah
there's no way I could barely do it at
30. that's how I just turned 32. so I'm
thinking I have so many things I need to
do it's not that I don't want a child
it's just I got to be there for
everything yeah I don't want to be I'll
see you tonight after work yeah I'll see
you 10 I'll see you tomorrow we'll play
tomorrow because my parents were not
there whatsoever so when it comes to
Teen Mom what made you hop in and want
to get involved with well they asked me
to host those reunions which are really
just interviews of what their lives are
all about I mean I'm not involved in
producing it I'm not involved in
anything but I heard the premise which
is you record people's choices and you
make sense of them it's Loveline it's
the same thing and so I I thought this
will impact teen pregnancy I know it
absolutely 100 and now they have two
academic studies that show the higher
the viewership of Teen Mom 16 and
Pregnant the lower the pregnancy rates
really yep two studies it's very clear
you could see your mistakes that you're
about to make exactly they they really
don't know until they see their peers
struggling and you know babies are no BS
they're impossible and they oh to them
it's this magical loving bundle of joy
no and so they see it and see it and see
it and we we tell the stories over and
over again and guess what they're always
the same which is impossible the
relationships don't last their lives are
overwhelmingly distorted by the this
choice and now I'm so proud of many of
these girls who I've now been with 11
and 12 years
they're starting to say uh when they're
they're coaching some of the younger
girls coming up and they're saying hey I
I was really I had issues I was sick and
I've had therapy I'm a lot better you
need to do the same thing I mean there
are children having children that aren't
developed yet what do you expect well
not only that in many situations having
a pregnancy during teen years is a
symptom of something else it's like
other adolescents don't manifest with
the usual symptomatology of adulthood
like when they when they get depressions
or major psychiatric illness they change
their attire they turn their fingernails
black they tap themselves up they change
their angst change their person they're
whom they're hanging out with they
change their sleep patterns change their
appetite pattern they get pregnant they
get STDs they have when it's all kinds
of unwanted outcomes around drugs and
alcohol all that those are all symptoms
of mental ill mental psychiatric
pathology so they don't know how to I
don't want to say major mental illness
no they're there's there were
traumatized oftentimes they were
abandoned they're disregulated they're
trying to solve the problems of how they
feel and the culture doesn't help them
Solve IT Health in a healthy way and the
things they use drugs truancy sex make
things worse
I I get that I wanted to bring something
up Marty told me you need to bring that
up okay you start talking
um Bart is your fault whatever comes
next I uh my mom had me at 18 my sister
at 16 my dad was a year older there
listen I don't want to be insensitive to
there are culture that's why I said it
oh it's often yeah often the case not
necessarily the case because there are
cultural issues as well that well the
reason I I wanted to bring it up is uh
seeing my mom's struggle made me made me
100 celibate as a kid I didn't want to
be with any girl I'm
I mean I'm in high school I talk to
girls and when it gets that point I go
oh no no no thank you because you're
going to get pregnant and I'm going to
be in the same exact situation good for
you so that that was the thing but they
were both drug addicts when I was
growing up yeah
um everything was really bad my dad was
never around and then oddly enough my
mom is a Mexican Well Jewish Mexican
lady
I was raised by white supremacists my
Mom married wow oh my God that's such an
interesting combo I know we never really
think about it and I'm Brown and don't
speak Spanish in a Spanish town so it
was very hard for me to grow up oh my
God you don't understand let me make
sure I heard you right Jewish
Mexican-American mom yes white skinhead
Supreme white real white supremacist
like a real deal
how does he explain the mom
my mom looks white but still she's cute
Grandma hated it and your grandma was
completely Jew like Jewish Jewish
polished fascinating we were like a
cultural weird
like three shows mixed together uh
unicorn you're just culturally unicorn
but the thing is the reason I bring it
up I see all my town is terrible yeah
all the stuff I stayed out of gangs yeah
all the bat did never made me want to be
involved is that because I was telling
myself one in a million because I should
be [ __ ] up the real conundrum in it is
his mod ruled with the iron fist though
oh he was scared in a good way
well she'd punched me in the face
and predominantly gang Town yeah so
you're you're a living breathing example
of resiliency that that trauma I don't
know you know we don't know enough well
enough to really know what's really
going on inside but trauma usually
really derails people and physical abuse
is trauma particularly the hands of the
people that are supposed to be helping
you develop your emotional landscape it
can it it can essentially causes you to
exit the frame of closeness that you
need to be in to develop an emotional
system
you don't strike me as having had that
happen you might have a little bit of
that of course you were traumatized well
the thing I never let it affect me
because I'm like oh yeah I should beat
the [ __ ] out of me when I'm 18 I I am
[ __ ] out of here that's how I thought
well that's how that's how kids think
when they're being abused they think
they leave permanently the the good news
is you didn't leave right then which is
what most kids do yeah I could I mean I
also have a 4.0 student played Captain
of my typical so do you have siblings
yes machine okay so in the sisters
should have [ __ ] me up a lot so in
families like that there's usually a
savior who's perfect and then a
scapegoat so I'm guessing your sister
was a bit of the scapegoat that's why
she hated me but she was also the only
one doing bad I know but this is this is
how this goes in family completely
perfect that's exactly what the
situation yeah there's the perfect
Heroes you know it has different
versions but it's sort of Hero perfect
whatever you you survive that way she
survives by acting out pathologically
yeah my sister's been to some
psychiatric places like that sure that's
the more normal that in the sense of
statistically
that's a more usual way that this goes
really I thought that was just a one in
a million no no the way your sister went
you're you're the unusual okay okay and
and so in your case what will happen is
it'll start affecting your relationships
you'll start getting involved with
people that are like I've only had one
girlfriend I'm gonna marry and we just
got engaged I I always saw it as I can't
get pregnant I can't have a kid with
somebody I don't want to spend the rest
of my life with well but what really is
going on is intimacy is a dangerous
place because your mom and if you were
able to bridge that and be intimate with
somebody who's actually available for
intimacy oh yeah
oh thank you you did it because I always
look at it as I don't ever want to be
involved in what they had to go through
I get it I get my kid through that but
what's what the perspective that you
seems like you had
we got my coveted cough here sorry about
that it's all good uh the perspective
that you had was able to you it seems
like for some reason you were able to
see your parents as humans who were
flawed not kids not horrible monsters
who were you know oh yeah no I knew my
mom just was 16 and stuck yeah it's
unusual to have that perspective and
usually be able to take that because any
kid you're so in it you know it's just
I've always said I've had the same mind
since I was a little little kid so
nothing has changed his wife which is of
wanting to do the best I possibly can I
don't really have the uh my mom used to
beat me I'm gonna do these because I did
do drugs my whole life I sold drugs
until I was 24 25. ah you left that part
out oh yeah yeah I used to sell hundreds
of pounds of weed I used to do a lot of
Coke and a lot of excess I mean that was
my I'm from Merced it's a drug how did
you not get strung out or did you well
what happened was I was doing coke every
single day and then when I realized like
I'm waiting for the blood to stop so I
can keep going yeah
um then I saw my dad doing crank my
whole life my mom doing math I just
thought all his childhood friends are
strung out every almost all of them so
it doesn't seem like you've got the
genetic potential for this
in other words you had something that
made it good made you made you like it
but I love it but it's just bad for my I
always say addiction is when you can't
stop addict addicts can't stop no matter
how bad it cuts for them because I'd
rather do good than
be [ __ ] up I wasn't like getting
[ __ ] up when I was a kid are you
completely absent now are you I just
smoke weed into mushrooms you got to be
careful because because if you have that
Gene it'll it'll keep it'll resurrect
and see it'll start to build I just love
I used to love Co I used to a lot of
colors I love it it's not a normal
relationship with it because it wasn't
bad for me if it wasn't just saying I
love it it's hard to undo that you know
what I mean
it's like I love sugar too and I have to
be really careful with it yeah no I
don't touch Coke at all because it's
just like really inspired by Chris
Farley basically that's it I just don't
want to pull like the fat guy like yeah
you're doing great the weed which is of
course far better we'll start to
escalate it someday you gotta be really
careful if you have it I don't know if
you have this genetic thing you're a
quarter pound a week and I it's all I do
is smoke weed I get it I'm trying to
wrap my head around like it's just that
it's gonna be evolved if you have the
gene for addiction which I don't know
that you do oh if you have it it's it it
addictions appear that people miss about
addiction it progresses always it or
even if you get it under control for a
while it'll progress later and the
progressive Pete is what you have to
watch out for my dad has that bad he
stopped doing meth picked up drinking
yeah because that's crossing over that's
crossing over it's a little different
but but even though he crosses over to
alcohol the alcohol will keep getting
worse oh it got bad yeah yeah when we
did the intervention for drugs turned
into alcohol was he in the program now
mine has been clean but I mean in the
program is he working a 12-step oh he
did that like 12 years ago so he's off
of that now he hasn't drank at all he's
completely straight edge now which is
unreal to me because you know my whole
life going to meetings
um no he just might ask him about that
so why doesn't go to meetings and stuff
I mean my dad's a truck driver he
constantly works and I have three
younger siblings so he's like the dad
take him to soccer practice going to
their school I get it I get it so he has
like a purpose I feel now she's asking
him ask him about meetings I used to go
to his meetings like with his uh stand
up I'm addicted to this yeah but I'm
wondering how he gets by without doing
it now does he have a therapist or
something or he's Mexican he doesn't
have it
it's just the truth [ __ ] yeah I mean
I've never seen a doctor besides the
clinic besides right now you and me so
I've never been yeah I've been to the
free clinic as a kid well get yourself
some health insurance oh yeah that that
I have now okay but um I just wanted to
ask because
when Marty's like you gotta talk to him
about your life I just wanted to okay
I've never asked anybody because
I just want to know like so it's an
anomaly basically yeah
[ __ ] up yes you're normally okay yeah
I just want to do that you have a super
healthy relationship and don't have kids
in our business so you can attest to the
relationships we're best friends because
she's my best friend of all time I hang
out with her over everybody are you
passionate about her you're like she's
the coolest person ever yeah she's
awesome yeah but the uh I wanted to
bring something else up we get we were
supposed to do a a episode a couple
weeks ago or about a month ago you and I
yeah with your manager but the schedules
got crossed we were really excited for
you to come in
I'm gonna talk about Marty because
Marty's had a really bad relationship
with his mom his dad take it away you
you talk you know it was just ironic
because yeah my mouth was like going
through a lot of medical stuff that I
was stemmed from a lot of psychological
stuff that we did a whole episode on and
she ended up passing last month oh I'm
so sorry yeah
like we were like Dr Drew we gotta talk
to your mom how are you gonna help him
because his relationship with his mom is
torn what'd she die of it's still up for
debate you know it was it was something
where she had a bunch of symptoms she
they could couldn't identify and she was
in the hospital she had like diabetes
she had a bunch of kind of like
not taking care of yourself she was
depressed she had a lot of that going on
how was she 65 was she obese yeah was
she able to move about was she we're
just like not towards the end so much
she started getting all these see the
thing was we had this stupid falling out
when she was up here she went back to
Texas but she had covid and then when
she went back she got vaccinated after
having covid and then maybe three four
months later she just started having all
these crazy symptoms like unexplainable
like her legs giving out and just like
wow diarrhea and just it just cycled and
spiraled until eventually she passed oh
I'm so sorry that that does not sound
psychiatric that sounds medical well it
was very medical I think it started as
psychiatric in terms of like she was
going through a deep depression still
the only thing I will ask the only thing
psychiatric I would ask about is
whenever I'm evaluating a medical case
and I'm like what the hell I I often
times I find drugs and alcohol were
actually part of the story is that any
part of the story I don't think so yeah
straight edge yeah I don't think so it
doesn't sound like it actually so
grief from losing my dad and it just
spiraled into like a depression that for
the past 10 years and then it just like
she just kind of gave up and then these
symptoms just like over but Mark you
have to explain Marty is one of those
Martin was one of the spiritual ladies
that believed she can speak to the dead
stones and goes she's very holistic and
she's she believed that anything can be
cured with me was she following up with
her doctors properly or no she wasn't
she wasn't even helping herself I was we
were going through that whole struggle
of me convincing her like oh God who
knows what this was then I mean there's
so many things that's why I didn't want
to get two in the weeds with it because
a lot of it's really unknown but the
real question was is that I in my heart
feel like it was a complication from the
vaccine well I'm not going to pretend
there aren't complications of the
vaccine I'm very pro-vaccine I've had
the vaccine you have the vaccine no no I
I've had coffee twice but I've had I had
J J my family's mostly all triple
vaccinated I recommend it to patients I
will tell you for sure there's a giant
difference with Omicron and people have
been vaccinated and particularly triple
vaccinated versus not I've seen Omicron
kick the crap out of people really are
not vaccinated it is milder it's a cold
if you've been triple vaccinated it
really is milder somebody like me I have
natural immunity then one J and J and
then Omicron got me that's interesting
so the vaccination makes it less it can
make it less and that's its main that's
its main that's the vaccination's main
job is boost your immune system against
it so it can fight it off when you
didn't understand it yeah the idea is
not to die not to go in the hospital
that's the idea of everything we're
doing with with the coronavirus having
said that yeah the [ __ ] goes down with
everything we do as doctors of course we
these are this is desperate times and so
we're taking aggressive measures to keep
people from dying keep them out of the
hospital so I I do believe strongly that
every individual should make his or her
choice with their doctor right there
will be no doctors very rare doctors
telling a 72 year old with obesity and
diabetes not to get vaccinated I mean
that you get fat you would get
vaccinated but if you or a 19 year old
or I we got to talk about that we'd sit
and think about the risk and benefits
and how you feel about it and like we do
everything in medicine and now we have
Pax levit and now we have molded pirovir
that we can't get it because the
government is so
[ __ ] incompetent at Distributing it's
a scandal but you can't get it if
actually somebody got it outside of
Merced interestingly really sort of in
that area how far from Sacramento is
Merced uh hour and 40. yeah I think it
was near Merced where a friend I had a
guy I know that had to get it for his
mother-in-law he heard me talking about
it it really works amazing drug but he
also heard me saying it's scandalous you
can't get it so he searched far and wide
I was able to find it in a pharmacy
outside of Sacramento hours what is this
drug uh it's a it's a triple antiviral
it really works again if you got sick
with coven I'm not sure I'd give it to
you because not worth the risk all
medication has risk all vaccine has risk
back to your concerns
and the the weird reactions I've seen
have been weird I've seen some weird
reactions to the vaccine uh and it
really brushed me off it does worry me
it does and and I would say I've seen
Long Haul I have a friend of mine's got
long haul covered from Coke from uh from
vaccine weakness and shortness of breath
and diarrhea and so in your mom who is
already sort of marginal if she were to
get a syndrome like that maybe that was
enough to kind of push her over I don't
know yeah that's what it seemed like
well that's one of the things it occurs
to me but there's 30 other things that
could yeah let's be fair she could add C
difficile she could have neurological
problem and she just got it did not get
a proper evaluation yeah I mean I I it
would have spent personally evaluating a
case like that would have taken a week
in the hospital you know we we would
have been doing spinal taps and Mrs and
mras and we've been doing everything uh
and doesn't sound like she got any of
that yeah which is sad sad and I don't
know there's anything could have been
done I don't know but it I agree with
it's the combination of medicine and
Psychiatry which is
always rough you know but the medicine
part is where it sounds like it didn't
go well no and I I always like I always
knew she needed she needed therapy from
the time she was a kid then she needed
another layer of therapy from like my
dad dying stuff we went through he
fought cancer for 10 years but I just
knew like without that and she wouldn't
do it that was the problem she would not
truth it's the craziest thing to me when
people won't take advantage of Mental
Health Services let me just for your
sake of you and your audience Mental
Health Services work they pay dividends
every time you don't have to get deep in
and a lot of people are fearful that
somehow something unpleasant is going to
be uncovered or revivified it's not how
it works it's not how it works the way
it works is
a good therapist and I dare say anybody
licensed is going to walk you into stuff
you can tolerate you don't want to
overwhelm somebody you want to give them
dosing that they can tolerate and make
you able to manage and regulate these
things as you walk into them that's it
and sometimes it takes some medication
and for a while if you have medication
great it works it helps that's it pretty
simple your brain gets sick just like
everything else perfect we have our one
of our things for the audience is speak
talking because we have a lot of people
reach out to us about mental health it's
so common fishing Now cover we destroyed
people especially young people staying
in oh you can imagine being 16 not being
able to see anybody that eight or 15
year olds were just oh what we've done
to them I'm so angry at this whole thing
I saw it coming guys I I didn't see I I
missed how contagious this thing is and
and I missed how you know the cytokine
storm thing I didn't get that at the
beginning but I saw the Panic that the
Press was trying to cause and ultimately
did and I knew the Panic would have
terrible effects
and here we are there we are so we had
bad enough this super contagious thing
with lots of horrible side horrible
consequences and then the Panic on top
Panic never makes things better ever
ever I just kept saying just don't
listen to these people don't listen to
The Press Listen to faucy listen like I
said I've been dealing with fauci since
1983. sonafachi listened to CDC but then
everything got crazy yeah everything I
mean we've talked about it before I
can't watch the news because I watch one
news station they tell me something and
the next one is completely contradicting
it's it's awful I don't and I I stay
purple like me stay in the middle just
stay reasonable though all the extremes
are streams are never good Panic is
never good to hear that from him right
now I try to just stay just keep using
your mind don't don't get sucked into
the propaganda on either end it's just
so so bad do you feel like even at this
point two years into this do we have
like an effective pandemic response if
this were to happen again at all the
answer that is a fantastically complex
question my to to distill it down to a
simple answer absolutely not it's
terrible and until we really really get
honest about what went wrong here we're
not going to have a good one we could
yeah we could and if we learn from this
we could and I hope we will right now we
do not if another wave oh I don't want
to think about it yeah I just want to go
back to yeah yeah yeah right I want my
life back yes
this is this is the stuff that made me
so upset at the very beginning they're
like oh you don't you don't want to make
money and work so it's greed is more but
no I want to be around people I love
people I want to be near people I want
to engage with people I want to push
Society forward in a positive way that
requires us all be in the same room some
of the time it just does and the the
fact that people were didn't understand
that that's the I mean what do we do I'm
all right you've got me going here guys
this this my thing is human thriving I
like humans to thrive right I like them
to be to every day going to be excited
about their life and their contribution
and what they're doing in the world and
their relationships and and their
Recreation and all the things that
thriving that's why when an addiction
I'm not interested in
look uh harm avoidance and medication
management all this stuff it's good help
saves lives I'm not interested in it I'm
interested in creating people like your
dad taking them from really a problem to
better than they ever knew they could be
when I saw that happen I was in the
psychiatric hospital working I was doing
just medicine in there and I saw this
happen to some people I'm like what is
that how did that happen this woman was
dying and now she's amazing how did that
what I I was just bewildered by it and I
became fascinated by it and that's how I
got involved in treating addictions
really that was actually my next
question for what I've seen Maine like
Marty was telling me I remember VH1 I
remember Celebrity Rehab I used to watch
that with my Grandma and Grandpa I
remember that show
is that something you're more passionate
about than you said just medicine it's
it's about fixing people or trying to
fix them where they can live their life
I I'm I'm interested in making a
difference
uh
you know in medicine
you're often going from like really sick
to chronically ill and and that's okay
uh and and you know old very old people
are what need to see internists like me
and and I love them and I love helping
them but but you're not making a young
person go from losing their life they're
dying to being amazing that's like holy
crap where do you get to do that that's
kind of thrilling to me that's how every
doctor should think of you well but but
I I'm not but I'm not EX look I like
treating schistosis and interesting
medical illnesses and
the leukemias and things I like all that
and I like helping people through that
uh it's look and like when it comes to
like I'm a process I have prostate
cancer right and I certainly well yeah
12 years ago I had a prostatectomy and
uh my surgeon I don't want him doing
anything else except that surgery I want
him doing that surgery three times a day
and not thinking about anything else not
counseling anybody on nutrition not
thinking about health maintenance I want
him doing that surgery and not having
complications from taking people's
prostate out when I sat down with him I
was like well what's you know what's the
deal how much what's your complication
rate he goes well I've done 1100 and
thus far zero I went okay let's go let's
keep doing that just keep doing that and
which he has
um that's amazing and uh yeah that was
12 years ago wow wow so do you just a
super health nut about this how do you
keep things regulated
so when you lose your pro you want to
get into it
yeah except when you lose your question
all right so I impressive cancer my fan
my dad had my uncle had it they both had
in their 70s so I figured it does run in
families like that and I figured all
right I'm gonna get it but in your 70s
you treat it very differently you treat
it with radiation and implants and other
things uh when I got out of 50 I was
like God are you kidding me at 50 I'm
getting this thing it's like they're
ridiculous this is ridiculous but okay I
got it and I went I was called active
surveillance you don't have to it's a
very slow tumor so you don't have to get
it out right away so I was surveyed for
years and uh and then when the things
started growing they're like okay now
you got to get it out so like two years
of surveillance out fine took it out
um you don't produce semen anymore
but yeah that's your prostate is what
produces semen all of it that's so when
you take your breast out you don't
produce it anymore but everything else
God willing if the surgeon goes right
surgery goes right completely normal
everything completely normal
and so other than no mess I I have no
other effects from it now I had a little
recurrence uh six months ago I had to
have some radiation during the summer
and that's sort of typical for this kind
of thing so that's all the prostate does
it's a well it does a lot of stuff it
produces it produces the semen so the
sperm can be dripped into it so it has a
vehicle to get yeah it seems so deadly
like when you hear about it Opposite
cancer well it's a it's an Adeno it's an
it's a gland and glands when they get
cancerous which they often do it can be
problematic if you if you're going to
get a cancer get prostate cancer strong
it's not pancreatic cancer do not
confuse the two pancreatic cancer is
curtains pancreas is curtains that's
curtains really prostate is you can live
with it for decades look I'm 12 years in
I have nothing and um
uh but anyway back to what the prostate
does it's also an immune organ it
prevents stuff from getting it cleans
cleanse your oyster lubricates your
urethra sends you know it keeps [ __ ]
from getting further up into your your
genital tract from your urethra so
I have no idea and I went through school
and they never taught me any of that
about the process where was colon cancer
following all this that's what my dad
had a colon is very common uh no one
should have that you should be getting
colonoscopies now they're saying every
year after 40 or every three to three to
seven years I beg your pardon uh and
it's just you just get them and and
polyps occur in the colon and they turn
into Cancers and what you do is you have
a colonoscopy and you pull out the
polyps before they become cancerous but
it's like a skin cancer or something so
it's avoidable a hundred percent no one
should be getting colon cancer in this
country you should be getting your
colonoscopies how long have we known
that and we've been doing it over 50 at
over the age of 50 for the last 20 years
30 years so but there's another thing
you're this so for older folks out there
is let me give a little piece of advice
you can do there's a there you can do
genetic testing there's a really good
service that I use called color.com
c-o-l-o-r.com uh just a cheek swab and
you you get your genetic profile that
screens for some of the more common DNA
repair abnormalities in other words your
DNA is always replicating and repairing
itself and some people have less
efficient particularly Jews less
efficient ways of repairing the DNA and
sometimes that repair mechanism makes a
mistake and that becomes a Cancer and I
have something called Lynch syndrome it
turned out and Lynch predisposed to
colon cancer my dad had polypsy on
polyps my uncle had stomach cancer part
of the deal too so now I have to get an
upper and lower endoscopy every freaking
year so do my sons they have the same
thing they started them in their 20s
based on the report you got based on
this genetic report yeah and do we not
have this genetic testing I would have
known I'd be still on a three to five
year schedule but I'm on an every year
schedule and I can have one in a couple
of weeks I heard you so so colon cancer
isn't hereditary then it is that's what
I'm saying it is the polyps are the
whole thing is the polyps are the
precursor to the cancer and it's all has
a genetic component to it it's not
necessarily genetic but it has a genetic
so like you should definitely be getting
cold outside what we're saying is you
got to go to the doctor yeah well you're
40 or 35 yeah 40s when they just lowered
it down to I think 40. so but you could
talk I had my first one in my 30s
because I had a hunch there was too much
cancer in my family and so I had my
first one in my 30s and so that's now
you and you could do the color thing
it's only 200 bucks yeah and it's it's
ridiculous that would have been twenty
thousand dollars five years ago you know
it's 20 bucks or 200 bucks rather and it
you'll know if you have any of these
there's about 30 of the more common uh
risk risk for cancer broccoli heard a
broca gene for breast cancer brca1
bracket two dude your your educational
system
your grandma's Jewish you must be
rolling over yeah she wasn't enough she
was watching the prices right the whole
time
[Music]
or like I said the VH1 we used to watch
Liberty rehab with my grandma Dolores
yeah that was that show did what that
was another show that I knew would have
a positive impact because it's against
cases cases showing what really happens
to people and people in spotlights that
are put on the pressure that we can't
even imagine well nah no no but but it
but it's but it's a again a more more
it's a hook it makes you watch because
oh I know that guy from Grease some of
the actual people themselves the
celebrities is it being a celebrity is
not a stressful thing don't don't
believe that [ __ ] I mean if you're
Justin Bieber's I mean it's a different
thing but if you're just uh like you
know somebody in the public me
people come up to you they're nice you
get a better place in the restaurant
that's it that's it that's it if you
like people it's an advantage because
people interact with you a little more
which I love people so great yeah that's
it so dealing with these celebrities
it's just it's not celebrities with
addictions all the same the only thing
that was different about them uh well
two things are different about them
because they often make a lot of money
doing their stuff as a celebrity and
they like it they love it they're
stratified by it they typically go back
to work too soon so going back to work
too soon risks their recovery and that's
musicians comedians all of them that's
the big problem and then the other thing
is
they all develop a pseudo self for the
media in other words like a front like
not one person had used their real name
they all had pseudo names and they're
who they really were were a little
different than what they presented on TV
and what was interesting for me is I
don't use my real name you know that but
I don't but I feel like I myself in all
these environments but maybe I'm not
maybe maybe I I don't know what it is
that makes people do that I think it you
know I discussed it with them I'd bring
it up with people and they'd all kind of
say well play a character and I you know
that's where I gets my success but I
think it's also a fear of vulnerability
of being them real their real self in
out in public it's an interesting social
media these days you can I mean with
certain platforms story I'm dying to
tell you because hey what's up guys just
taking a quick moment to talk about one
of our sponsors this is FanDuel I'll get
right into it any new customer that
downloads the FanDuel Sportsbook app and
uses our code dope as usual we'll be
eligible for this deal and that deal is
BET five dollars when 280. Yes you heard
me right five dollars can win you 280.
all you have to do is download the app
use our code dope as usual and you're
eligible and yes for everyone out there
wondering yeah Marty and I are not happy
both our teams lost in the most
devastating way I know the Rams are a
better team but I'm gonna put my money I
mean it's five dollars to win 280. I'm
gonna put my money on the Niners and
don't forget use our code dope as usual
when you download the app five dollars
could win you 280 any team and again
guys I'm not gonna say everything but on
the screen right here this is all the
rules you know you cannot bet unless
you're 21. make sure your state allows
betting so for Super Bowl 56 there's no
better place to be betting than FanDuel
Sportsbook prop bets parlays five
dollars can win you 280 any team they're
always doing something awesome here on
FanDuel for new customers or existing
I'll say it again download the app use
our code dope as usual dual five dollars
can win you 280. it's a no-brainer
what's up guys taking a quick moment to
talk about one of our long time sponsors
this is better help let's just be honest
guys a lot of us have problems that we
don't talk about a lot of us have
problems that our parents our best
friends our husbands or wives don't know
about and it should not be that way it's
almost taboo for especially for men to
talk about their feelings openly so
sometimes you just need someone to talk
to talk it out when you can hear
yourself talk about your problems it's a
lot less stressful when you hear the
situation because a lot of us just
thinking in our heads and overthink I'm
guilty of it so if you're out there and
you need help and you don't want to go
to a therapist and sit in the waiting
room and maybe see somebody from town
now they think that you have something
wrong with you even though something's
not wrong with you you just might need
to get it off your chest if this sounds
like you do me a favor go to
www.betterhelp.com forward slash dope
and that's 10 off your first month with
a certified therapist this is completely
discreet you can be in your own home in
your own bed talking to somebody that
can help you so guys this is not a
crisis hotline this is a long-term
therapy session so once again go to
www.betterhelp.com forward slash dope
and that's 10 off your first month of
treatment you could do this from your
own home it's convenient it's affordable
and it's 100 confidential
because Dennis Rodman's name is Dennis
Rodman and I have the greatest
interaction dentists and I are really
good friends now and I and he promised
we would be and he was a dentist is an
incredible person and uh my first
interaction it was so fantastic he was
in a group we had a group with a really
intense group with lots of people having
emotions and stuff and he the whole
group held a book up to his face and was
like reading like moving his lips
reading for to a two-hour group and he
was right to my right and uh at the end
of the group I was like Dennis come on
man I mean you see what's going on here
these people are having they're putting
themselves out they want you to be a
part of it come on you know this goes
hey he goes I'll tell you something
raises his boys you notice and he goes
uh you and I are going to have a
relationship we'll do that but if we're
gonna do it you gotta understand one
thing
and he he held his giant arm up but like
this I'm I'm making a ledge way above
his head and he goes he goes here is God
and then he moved his hand down about an
inch and he goes and here's professional
athletes and you gotta understand that
if you understand that you and I are
gonna be fine and I literally I laughed
out loud I did nobody defend him all
right does I get it I got it all right
all right fine okay what a statement
yeah and uh doctor and what's weird is
that's really not how he is which is so
funny to be in retrospect now that I
know him he's actually
he's not like that is he preparing you
for his ego is that what he I don't know
what really that was I someday I'll ask
him what that was all about because he's
actually kind of a humble guy in his own
little way and uh and his daughter now
is a famous soccer player and oh I
didn't know oh yeah she's awesome she's
amazing and uh are you baffled when the
whole North Korea thing happened with
him oh I loved it not only did I love it
I called him I called him I said Dennis
did you ever imagine Dennis Rodman and
Nobel Peace pies would come out of
somebody's mouth in the same sentence
ever we had a good laugh about it he um
he his brain doesn't work the way our
brains do in both for better and for
worse and so he sees stuff that we don't
all see necessarily and that was quite a
move it was it was like a movie scene
parody going that was a great thing
Dennis Rodman I love them I really have
deep deep affection for him and he's a
he's he's
I wish his alcoholism was still kind of
an issue and stuff just for him he
doesn't no one else hurts except him but
I wish he'd really he gets it under
control periods of time and then not I
worry about him that's all well so back
to what you were saying earlier no no
what you were saying earlier it's it's
there
they're making water for something else
yeah I'll do that good idea I've got
water they're making it for something
else you're saying he keeps going back
to alcohol spurts and this he loves it
that's why when you say you love the
cocaine I worry about it when you love
something it's not it's hard to get not
to go back well I just I know it's bad
for me so I'll never touch it again in
my life but you love it oh yeah well we
can be friends at a distance
if you could do that you're not a drug
addict I'm not yeah I think I'm not yeah
but I do love drugs but they're bad for
you he's the biggest weed influencer
online just so you know oh that yeah you
do you got to be careful my daughter had
horrible consequence from which she's
now in recovery it's not for everybody
it's the point some people it really and
we were made together yeah like some
people that really takes them down and
other people they can go forever with it
oh yeah we mean well wait like Marty too
Marty's a workaholic just like I am
we're non-stop until midnight
and um I mean I'll smoke weed all day
just because it's like you know what yes
I will smoke a bowl cool I don't go do
all my recipes it's there's something
about the biological relationship with
it I mean for some people it's a nothing
it's no big deal for other people it has
progression and they can't stop and
they're using it inappropriately it
affects their everything affects their
moods and all kinds of stuff I've seen
I've seen that definitely when it comes
to concentrates because it's so strong
yes I think that's I think that's
exactly right I mean if you're doing
dabs it's like I'd look into this I mean
I do have a lot but for me my thing it's
my profession this is what I do I do
reviews I do this I've been doing it for
10 years I'm not telling you you sure
because you seem fine to me it just it
just worries me from the progression
standpoint that it could lead to
something else not that it's going to no
I see what you're saying that it could
but there'll be some days where I'm like
did I even smoke weed yeah from the
outside looking in he actually you're
smoking way with less weed than I used
to used to I used to smoke at least yeah
see that's your you're a kind of unique
biology right this whole of this kind of
I'll take it or leave it kind of thing
go work and get things done like that's
your Jewish grandmother's influence it
goes genetically not by a lot not
socially genetically it's something
because I have a lot of drug addicts in
my family a lot both parents yeah so and
your sister my sister now she just
smokes and she is the hardest working
person ever Oh I thought she had she
went oh no messages awesome oh so she's
good now okay she's a good job she's
just so good for her oh okay great oh my
sister's great but as a kid it was just
me and her because it was just me and
her then my mom had a kid when I was 15
and then my dad had three kids right
after that because they're different
different so I was just me and her until
16 and then my dad Brady Bunch he
married someone four kids and had four
kids so I have little brothers eight how
was that living in a household like that
I was out I left at 18 I was just doing
my own thing for absence now
um but I had a question real quick
something I asked Marty about in the in
social media I get it's it's different
like you saying you start off radio
there was no information Google wasn't
there yeah
social media is super beneficial and it
also has its super downfalls
conscially I see it with kids because I
have little brothers little sisters
my question is do you think there should
be an age limit for kids to be able to
get social media I don't know how we do
all that but I do believe that one day
soon we will look upon this the way we
look upon tobacco
it seems to be very similar in terms of
how we will think about it lives get
ruined from that well right now the big
thing we're seeing is all the kids that
were given screens for school
drop the age of porn exposure down to
like eight
and and yeah and it was bad unless the
sexting and the pornography and all that
that was those screens were used for
ridiculous and they've got data on this
and it's just startling I can only
imagine being able to be in teenager
right now in my head going oh I'll talk
to 10 people in one minute send the same
message and while I'm watching who knows
what and what's and by the way it rains
down on them I have a I have a patient
as a teacher in my office last week and
she goes I can't tell you how often on
one of these kids screens a PornHub
comes up you know these are she's a
seventh sixth grade teacher you know
I was hoping to kind of get your advice
on this because I have a 13 year old
daughter
go to I there's a friend of mine who
runs a website called digitalcitizen
Academy
dcakids.org and uh she only lets her
kids on the screens an hour or two a day
and she's way into all of this her name
is Lisa strumming she have interviewer I
should probably interview with you Lisa
strowman okay
I've been running it into like just I
know as my dad it's my job to be that
brick wall the boundaries into like it's
really hard it's but then you it can
turn into long stretches of being that
and being of being of being like the bad
guy yeah I need this acceptable behavior
I need honesty I need these basic things
and I find myself I can't get like
dealing with a 13 year old is just so
different than what I ever imagined in
terms of like oh I'm kind of really
dealing with somebody that's completely
different and every all the advice I get
is like it's just gonna be like that
until one day it'll Circle back but two
things you should well three things to
keep in mind one is you're an [ __ ]
except that I've already told him
except that uh number two her frontal
lobes are not working and thank God it's
not a male because they really don't
work but it's a male they she's relying
on your functioning frontal loads to be
superimposed on her non-functioning when
you say frontal lobe executive function
judgment thinking reasoning the ability
to choose good you know subdominant
impulses when you really want to do
something not so good that's frontal
lobe uh that's the issue and then and
then three don't be afraid to get Mental
Health Services because only so much of
it is parenting you know and participate
in that I felt like so much of it is
just I've been getting we've been
getting everyone in my family I have
triplets where do you really 29 years
old now yeah and uh yeah and uh all of
us have had therapists at one time or
another and the system is at therapy and
this said every time it pays big
dividends every time yeah we just
started about a month ago and already it
just kind of is easier to communicate
through a third party and if even just
taking that extra step to make that
effort to do it I found helped
it's like I find myself in a position
where either I'm not going to be fully
paying attention and up in the mix yeah
and they're and is that what you have to
do basically at some point
like I'm not gonna be because it's like
with a 13 year old if you dig and dig
you're gonna find something that you
don't like yeah so at some point you
have to be like okay I'm not gonna dig
well trust that you do the right thing
well trust but verify yeah uh as soon as
soon assume they're not gonna do the
right thing always assume they're not
but uh because they're gonna push
boundaries that's their job I I would I
would unload some of that onto the
therapist like the therapist's job is to
make sure nothing bad is going on and to
help and to advise you how to approach
it
um I I make sure you're talking to the
therapist they may or may not tell you
everything it doesn't really matter the
important thing is just what do you
what's my role here what exactly should
I be doing give me some guidelines and I
will do it because it becomes a
full-time job micromanaging all these
things that you know like we were
talking about earlier kids want to use
vpns and get around your their Geniuses
they're just evil scientists when it
comes
oh yeah yeah they're amazing a little
brother does code yeah yes I'm already
done as the parent you're like okay I
need to monitor what you're doing make
sure everything's appropriate here but
it really releases Stroman in here at
least you can zoom her in or something
you need her yes
she's an expert in all this stuff and uh
nice yeah so because I know how to deal
with boys growing up because I was one I
don't know how to deal with girls my
sister is gay she was a very tomboy and
beat the [ __ ] out of her I didn't have a
regular sister yeah you know so I don't
even know how to do so you're gonna have
all girls don't worry so that's not me
that's fine with me but
um
yeah it's usually it's a tougher time
for the mom for a 13 year old girl oh
it's been equally she's even way more
immersed in it than I am okay so the
mom's having a tougher time yeah okay I
never even asked that's normal yeah
that's good totally she's way in the mix
I know I get it yeah yeah because they
they get triggered by it the women they
kind of see it know it they've been
there and they get and then you're just
triggered by me oh man they're many
times yeah many times during the teen
years when I would look at my wife and
daughter interacting I just go which
one's the adult I can't tell anymore
what's going on here
that way my sister's going through all
that my mom was going through it too
they were right there it was a it's a it
gets better it yeah it got better it got
better with time and just setting like I
said sitting boundary what is that just
let a lobe start kicking in for females
around 21 22. like really you can't see
it around that age for men it's like 27
28 yeah we're still Screwballs well into
our 20s oh yeah that's I can verify that
I know a lot of people doing stupid [ __ ]
in their 30s oh yeah you know well then
drugs prevent some of that development
so you have to be careful too that's
another thing like I said a lot of my
best well most of my best friends live
outside they're just strung out gone I
tried for years homeless outside yeah
outside that's math well it's meth and
now it's getting to heroin
yeah alcohol and math fentanyl that's
the that's the mix on the streets yeah
and people go just give a house just
give your friends a home that's all they
do drugs in there and burn it down of
course they will of course well they're
overdosing too many times it makes me
Furious when they're just like let's get
they need a house just get them at home
it's hiding it when you go out on the
street right now it's all drug addiction
25 mental health stuff but yeah that's
the myth is just out so that P2P stuff
forget it the stuff there there's a book
called the least of us by Sam Quinones
about the kind of meth that's coming up
now from Mexico like oh from Mexico it's
bad it's been really exactly it's like
crank and that makes people unbelievable
to scratch their skin off yeah this is
the same stuff it makes them psychotic
so fast yeah insane like bath salt
reactions right yeah okay yeah it's the
same same there's a house though come on
man they just beat somebody up in there
no I don't trust any of that even the
10s I mean people need to live but
there's drugs they need to go into
treatment they need to put them in
residential facilities large facilities
would look like that look at that
building over there now one of the
residential facility looks like that
let's help these people for God's sakes
yeah because there's still potential for
all these people I know people used to
be on track I'm telling you I'm that's I
all the time I'm dear friends that were
on the streets and they're all drug
addicts and they all are recovering now
and they're doing great it's amazing and
your experience like of all the people
you've treated is it a very small
percentage of people that really bounce
back or is it more than you think way
more than you think really I was seeing
I want to say this loud and clear I saw
something online that they were like oh
you know drug treatment should be
eliminated because any treatment that
has only 10 or 20 success rate is is not
and I'm like whoa that is not how it
works it takes on average five years and
four treatments or is it four treatments
in five years I think it's four
treatments in five years to get one year
of sobriety not because the treatments
are ineffective it's because that's what
it takes to get somebody into remission
you wouldn't say you know oh three
rounds of chemo got them to remission
well the first two were failures it's
like no no this is this is how we get
them there and more people get into full
recovery than you imagine
also a lot of people die a lot and I
think people are finally getting that
it's a fatal illness and if you don't
get to the sobriety you go to this you
go to the ground yeah I'm waiting for
the calls I'm just dreaded yeah I know
it takes a while it takes a while but it
goes there
jail which no one's going to anymore
institutions but you're not allowed to
put people in or death so death is where
they're going that's terrible yeah well
I said where I'm from Merced is if if
you're outside you're probably homeless
there's nobody walking there's no
joggers there's no bikers if you're on a
bike you stole it you made it that's
Merced it's it's a sad for the mayor's
happy with this uh Public Service
Announcement mayor's like 31 years old
yeah I think he's like 31 years old but
I said it before when I was 16. I want
to be the mayor Merced one day yeah go
do it you said you've got the goods I'm
gonna do it please one day I'm gonna win
like how different is La been since
growing up though just like that most
terrible like I can't imagine is nice
though passing is okay it still has its
own problems but but La is really and
look I'm Like a Surgeon that's seeing
cases all under his feet knows that he
can fix them but no one lets him I know
how to help these people it's killing me
five are dying on the streets every day
in Los Angeles that's insane I think
that sounds like 1500 people a year
interesting yes disgusting they should
not the people that allow that that's
Criminal
yeah it's like Corolla I grew up
listening to you and Adam and he always
[ __ ] about like I'm gonna get a
ticket if I park by the red but I could
set up a tent live on the same sidewalk
right like it's insane I'm from the east
coast and that's one of the main things
you notice when you come out here is
like how do American cities have this
well there's a great book called San
Francisco by a guy named Michael
schellenberger that he makes yeah he's
every single policy that's led to all
this he puts the whole thing out there
and it's very well done he's a brilliant
guy yeah we had a Rick Ross uh well
Freeway Rick Ross the track deal of the
cocaine dealer on the show and he was
telling us about the 80s and 90s when
the crack era just started he's like it
just ticks lives takes over complete
lives and I mean I've watched it and the
fact that my profession treated that as
a criminal issue really a shame makes me
shamed it was a medical problem and
magically when the opiate thing hit you
know White Middle America oh now it's a
medical problem unconscionable I I was
treating crack addicts back in those
days we did pretty good with them yeah I
didn't see it as a criminal promise I
was a drug addiction yeah they're set up
they're sick
the brain is taken over by these things
people can't understand that yeah
because I've had friends and I've seen
six months later I go well that is not
the same person yeah he's gone yeah
brain's gone that's right yeah and they
can be brought back to a point this is a
crazy thing to me about all this if
there's a dementia patient running
around the freeway and I don't help that
person I am ethically on the line I'm
I've I've hurt somebody I but if this
but if it's a meth addict out on the
street or a schizophrenic I'm not
allowed to get near them I'm not allowed
even to offer them Services no chance
and the meth addict and the
schizophrenic if you intervene early
they can be restored to normal or
towards or at least a productive life
the dementia patient is nothing I can do
that's only going to get worse but the
ones I can actually treat and make
better no sorry they're living their
best life you're not allowed to get near
them hey who are you to say man that
schizophrenic wants to live on the
street you're you're a big ableist get
out of here that's what people say yes
it's incredible it's incredible and the
longer you stay psychotic and
schizophrenia the less we can bring you
back the longer you're exposed to meth
the less we can bring you back and so
good job everybody so drug laws are
corrupt oh my God I wouldn't use words
like corrupt they're well-meaning and
they are killing people ineffective and
awful awful so no drug addicts should be
in jail they should be no they should be
in treatment of course it's ridiculous
what a difference it would make on our
overall Society just in that one change
yes if you could take somebody whose
brain isn't working right like we do
with dementia patients and go come with
me I'm going to help you let's just go
take them by the hand and take him and
go I got a bed for you here got nurses
you're gonna like it I promise it's
gonna be nice
come on how do we change this how what
do you have to do to make this mayor of
Merced
I'm pointing at you I mean maybe maybe
one town at a time like that I mean the
mayor of San Diego started doing some of
that falcon or is that his name and uh
and there's slow progress here but an
end of Villanueva seems to understand
that this could be done I don't know I I
give up I gave up I was gonna I
volunteer to be on a committee they
vilified me for being wanting to be on
that committee
you're a Trumper it's like what are you
talking about what do you how disgusting
you are and then they called me
anti-immigrant in the L.A times I'm like
oh [ __ ] it's like I'm an immigrant I'm a
second my family escaped the Ukrainian
genocide what the [ __ ] are you and we
are the square of course what the [ __ ]
are you talking about you're disgusting
that's the Press man that's the Press
today well you say stay purple like you
said just don't read the Press don't
read anything just know everything is
fake news everything on all sides just
read it with a half an eye and then try
to figure out what's really extra
frustrating when you're really trying to
help people oh my God it's unbelievable
and they're like I feel the frustration
ideology ideology destroys human beings
and these people are all ideologues they
what do they know about treating working
in a psychiatric hospital you ever
worked in a psychiatric hospital you
ever treated a patient with any of these
conditions oh never oh there's not one
doctor on these committees not one oh
supervising these sick people holy crap
yeah I want to hear where can we find
your podcast I know you have a podcast
on your mom's house so I have a bunch of
stuff so um I want to hear more about
this I stay away from it for the most
part because I get too frustrated but
but I do I do a podcast on with on
corolla's platform it's just called the
doctor Drew Patrick you can get
everything at drdrew.com and Dr drew.tv
and Dr drew.com I've got me and Adam we
do three days a week oh wow so we still
do a regular thing me and Adam for years
uh the Dr Drew podcast which is sort of
me interviewing experts that's more of
that uh I have at your mom's house which
is Tom segur and Christina P's thing uh
I have a thing called doctor after dark
which is
and technically comedy I mean it's it's
kind of a new incarnation of Loveline
where I'm answering those kinds of
questions but it's in a comedic
environment it pushes the envelope much
like Loveline did so that's why I'm
willing to do it uh then I have a show
called ask Dr Drew which is a streaming
show at least three four days a week at
3 P.M Pacific uh
TV four shows yeah you're busy yeah
you're busy I think there's more wait
hold on a second and you still
I do outpatient medicine I'm doing a lot
less than I used to oh my God so much
less I mean I used to get up at 5 30 in
the morning and struggled to get home by
10 at night struggle you know and half
my day in the hospital or at outpatient
practice and the other half day at the
psych hospital do a lot of other doctors
talk [ __ ] because you're like the famous
doctor and they look they used to
um they sort of tolerate me now uh they
they you know they
hey
the covet thing was such an
extraordinary experience that I think
the hospital Administration where I
worked one of the things that that
really was disgusting with kovid is
doctors stopped treating patients
because they just they were saying hey
just go home and come back when you're
sick come back when you're O2
saturations 88 they stopped doing
everything because they were afraid that
their Hospital Administration was going
to judge them or their peers were going
to judge them or social media was going
to attack them you know God forbid they
use something like hydroxychloric under
Ivory back then you know I they look you
could say stop trying anything and they
just said go go home come back when
you're really sick which is I've never
said I've never heard of such a thing
yeah um and so it was horrible that's
what they kept doing to my mom yeah and
and I it's horrible uh I uh that's this
is what has happened to Medicine what
she should have is a Doctor Who's like
calling her twice a day and looking
after her and thinking about her and
moving this thing forward you don't have
to do something but you have to monitor
your patients I know I I'm old timer I
guess but any event I started
complaining about this I had a nightly
show here on local news uh which was
sort of keeping up on you know what was
going on with covet during the first
year of covid and uh and I went to get
the vaccine like right away I'm like ah
I get this fixed it's perfect my
Hospital wouldn't give it to me why
because even though I was treating
coveted patients and I was volunt and I
wanted to work in the ER and I
volunteered no you're not from a risk
neighborhood and you're not one of the
hospital employees and we got to give it
to this first much same thing they're
doing with Pax levid and monocle of
antibodies right now same exact
philosophy and so running around the
hospital trying to get the vaccine I got
coveted that's how I got covered first
time and uh and how backward was that
well whatever I was there they were
doing it but I started complaining about
it on TV and I think I don't think they
like that yep that'll do it
why aren't you getting your vaccine and
screaming about people getting their
vaccine were originally restricting
people from getting it who won it was
very this has been such a horrible
experience this coveted thing it's from
the first time in history that the whole
world's dealing with this like I can't
that's what I can't believe is that the
whole world has gone as nutty as the
United States went I get we're nuts I
get it yeah I know I understand every
country I understand it's crazy but the
whole world did what we did that's
that's the weird part Australia did it
worse like all the good cousins that
came for Christmas are [ __ ] up too
that's how I feel like damn they're
[ __ ] up oh [ __ ] this is it just made
me feel like oh there is no like real
adults out there that have good for you
I think that's I think that's a nice
take on all this it's like what was this
what happened here it shows the
unorganization of Earth
[Music]
it doesn't have to be like this I I
don't know what caused everyone to go so
wacko but they're still kind of in it I
know they're still sort of in it like if
you're all this way you're all that way
if you're not like I said if I if I want
to help homeless people I'm a Trumper
what if I want to help almost if I want
to treat that's a new kind of like a
slow way of thinking I feel like though
it's it's histrionic
it's that what Dr Malone on Rogan called
uh Mass delusional psychosis that we're
talking about the same thing in
different different words I I would
start talking about a year ago I said
what I I saw the narcissistic turn in
this country I saw that we all became
narcissists I get I wrote a book about
it but we've now become histrionic which
I never expected and that's weird and I
kind of feel like it's a situational
thing what does that mean it's Trump and
fear and covid caused us histrionic is a
certain personality style of being sort
of excessively emotional and flamboyant
and swayed into Trends and you know the
excessive emotionality and delusional
and I sort of see people becoming
delusional in their thinking so rigid
unable to change that's delusionality
right and literally some of the things I
saw people saying public I'm like hey
are you two years ago I would have put
you in the hospital with those things I
would have you know your meth buddies
they're they're having those thoughts
and uh now it's commonplace so I think
that's going to settle down I think or I
think so too yeah I think we're sort of
settling although today interestingly
I've seen it flaring a little bit I
don't know why really I don't know why
it's weird I just saw it kind of coming
up again I'm like oh no come on
attacking when they start attacking
sensible people that's when I know
there's like something's going on yeah
when people are logical like I agree
like that don't you if you want to just
follow good
sensible Physicians on on social media
Twitter vinay Prasad excellent
oncologist I was a fan of his way before
covet he's just very penetrative ability
to read medical literature and think
it's a smart dude uh Monica Gandhi
g-a-n-d-h-i a infectious Z specialist up
in San Francisco UC San Francisco
excellent thinking very reasonable and
today they were getting a tax so it
upset me I was like why would you tag
these two oh my God they're so accents
well people trying that's probably why
so now now I'm exhausted guys if it's
awesome I'm sorry
guys I need to know let's smoke a bowl
so you don't smoke weed right I don't
well I have I have no objection to it
yeah
but but but I I um I told Rogan I would
do it on his show if it would help our
relationship
for saying that well that was like some
controversy he thought my relationship
he thought I was soup because I treat
people who for whom he gets out of
control and they can't stop and have
consequences I treat people who can't
stop doing things that's where I come in
and cannabis for some people that's a
that's it that's a problem he took great
offense to that I think I don't even
take offense and he's and we've healed
that since and I said if I'm sorry give
a [ __ ] or whatever but no invitation yet
so we'll see oh but that would be
amazing but but I I worry about doing
that frankly because I don't want to
it's such a political thing we have to
we'd have to do it very carefully and
think I have to have an opportunity to
really explain what I was doing but uh
what was I saying about all this
um oh I don't think I I think I'm sort
of resistant to cannabis the only thing
when I was in college I spoke many
several times I got panic attacks oh
yeah okay
and and by the way IFC hyperemesis now
all the time people that vomit from it
hyperemesis cannabis hyperemesis
syndrome if you're vomiting doing pot
pay attention it's a really serious
syndrome
um and now when I've used in the present
day I don't I don't really feel much
anything really it doesn't really do
much for me I think I'm sort of
genetically whatever just doesn't I know
that's shocking if you love it no no I
know I get it because I can smoke and I
mean we've done it we smoke a pound
joint I'm like I'm not that hot at the
end yeah I just feel tired I just feel
tired I'm ready to just to lay down have
you found kids aren't like smoking
though anymore right that's a nice big I
don't see a lot of Secrets anymore
foreign
and I'm not really worried about tobacco
I mean not tobacco nicotine vaping I
worry about tobacco tobacco is what
hurts people nicotine does not hurt
people but the theory is that nicotine
vaping leads to cigarettes if that's
true then I have a problem so nicotine
vaping not as harmful as it's made out
to be it's not harmful tobacco horrible
but tobacco is the enemy not nicotine
now if you now if you get exposed to
nicotine under the age of 17 it's very
hard to stop that's the problem oh yeah
I smoked two packs a day you're going to
be on the gum or something forever after
that but if you're 24 and you use
nicotine Vape to get off cigarettes
good by all means it's it's one of the
best ways to get off cigarettes my hands
everybody that's how they stop smoking
yeah but all the kids are vaping the the
not the oral fixation what are they
vaping just flavored stuff or whatever
yeah whatever I mean we were smoking
it's not good for kids that's not what I
call good for your lungs I'm not I'm not
advocating by any stretch I'm just
saying let's be reasonable about this
too that it's you know it may hurt their
lungs you know it's not good for you
growing up
please stop but the more you go into
Panic Zone about it that's again not how
you change health behavior you're gonna
have to show some kids that have some
bad outcomes from it that then they'll
change I started smoking my grandpa got
evazime and died I'm [ __ ] done
smoking cigarettes yeah yeah that's how
that's when I just stopped well I told
you the story yeah but um yeah no I just
wanted to ask the questions about the
podcast because I know there's a lot of
people right now going I need to hear
more about this well yeah I and if you
want if you if you what I do on my
streaming shows which are live uh I take
calls from Clubhouse and we also read
emails and stuff actually the emails you
can send into uh Dr Drew after dark
which is the Imam house thing I answer
lots of questions there that's uh Dr
Drew after dark Dr drewafterdark
gmail.com just send your questions there
we'll get to them it's so cool that you
do that yeah try to and uh and then on
the streaming show we I sign into
Clubhouse and I take phone calls off
Clubhouse wow how many times a week do
you do this stream at least three or
four times a week you are busy so we'll
do one at three o'clock today you know
oh right after this you're gonna go do
one
that's amazing yeah I need to I need to
get my uh schedule down what time do you
wake up let me ask and I listen I told
you I used to go to bed at midnight at
12 30 I'd get up at 6 30. now I go to
bed at 10 and get up at seven so it's
still reasonable yeah so I'm reasonable
I'm I'm sleeping plenty I believe in
sleeping when you're older I I'll tell
you sir when I was one of the many
million jobs I had was working at an
Alzheimer's hospital and when I first
got in there and I was trying to kind of
get to know the patients and I was
thinking why are these guys what if
there's something predisposed to this
and I was noticing in all the men's room
the I mean the men's bedrooms they had a
picture of themselves by the bedside
they were like Admirals or they owned
car dealerships they were like these
extremely accomplished people and I
thought oh it must be stress right it
must be stress it's causing that maybe
risking the Alzheimer's and I talked to
the family members and they I'd go visit
there they clearly it was an admiral
amazing they always have owned a series
of car dealerships was that stressful
for him they would all say the same
thing like oh no he loved it he loved it
and then I'd say did he sleep no never
slept because I thought oh I'm going to
sleep I'm getting sleep get some sleep
when you're older be sure he's barely
sleep now my whole life that's just
scared the [ __ ] out of me we'll get some
uh I tried what's the stuff later I saw
OG every day all day that's why I
started smelling she's like melatonin
try melatonin I tried like hundreds get
not asleep schedule is the best thing
I've ever seen my life a master of it
yeah
so you can't do it when you're on drugs
you can't really do it in your audience
but you the the most sleep
recommendations are these days get off
everything and just wait till sleep
happens like don't sleep don't sleep
build up what's called Sleep pressure or
sleep inertia and eventually you will
sleep and you'll be miserable in the
meantime you'll be terrible you have a
bad week but eventually you will sleep
yeah even that's sort of the Sleep
especially there's no way to fall asleep
for me well are you are you like a three
four hour night guy just that's just you
sometimes I'll be sleeping no no because
some people are just three four hour
night sleepers when I sleep three or
four hours I wake up like let's go do
some something but when I sleep six or
seven I'm just wake up kind of girl
maybe all you need as far as the night
there is those people there are those
people and those people get a lot done
I've noticed that I get a lot [ __ ]
yeah you may be one of those people well
that's the dimension thing kind of
scared me the whole time well you know
but that but I'm sure those were guys
like me were you know choosing not to
sleep like I was sleeping five six hours
a night it was awful did that for 20
years it's got you oh got you okay no
all right so Dr Drew uh.com is where we
can really drdrw.com for all the pods
and Dot TV for the streaming shows I
think that's the best way to do it and
it's not the most intuitive website you
you have to you have to scroll down on
things and you'll you'll fish around our
audience knows computers it doesn't like
jump at it you have to kind of look
around so
so please do I'd love to have your
audience around no I are this is and
whatever I do for you guys let me know
maybe we should like
have you as an extremely guest or
something if you want to promote
something let us know let us know yeah I
just like talking to people yeah
absolutely no you too I already know
haven't listened to you for so long you
knew this was gonna work no there's a
lot there that's super informative man
he pairs up so nicely with like you know
Ryan sickler oh yeah comedians well
sickler was on your mom's house too
right that was yeah yeah that was
Thomas's first ever podcast was yeah the
first one I ever did was a year before
we did this as a guest on his yeah oh
yeah Ryan's the best he's hilarious yeah
and just a great guy yeah on and off
he's just a funny dude a nice guy yeah
okay yeah
um Martin do you have anything else I
think this is your doctor everything I
want to show of course thanks for having
me I loved it sorry I had to now I'm
real guilty for having to reschedule but
I had to reschedule sorry about that but
Oh no you're fine let's do some more
stuff down the road we'll do other
things let's see what just see how your
audience takes on this our audience is
Young and you drop so much info we'll
see what they what they want to know
about what they're interested in and you
know maybe if you have a whole series of
like questions or things like that
very active audience thousands of
comments per episode so I already know
that like next time ask this can you
please ask okay well let's let's do that
I love that okay well thank you so much
thanks for coming on the show of course
this is uh good to see you guys it was
great well guys um sir this has been the
Dr Drew Episode
Marty O'Neal me thank you so much for
being here pleasure hopefully be back
soon you guys until next time thank you
so much for watching this has been the
dope as usual podcast have a dope ass
day
all right
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]